tension in between hosting the daily
briefing and appearing on the 5:00 every
day and she joins us so Dina what is
this a but this seems to come out of
nowhere all of a sudden everybody's
against electoral college tell us why
well it comes in cycles and I think the
last time I really remember hearing a
lot about it was after the election of
2000 with Democrats very bitter okay and
some ways understandably write that down
to the recount the Supreme Court it
makes that decision and you started to
hear this drumbeat if you know what this
is not fair this Democrats saying this
is not fair to us we win a popular vote
therefore we should win the presidency
doesn't that just make sense that's the
way it should be wait a second I didn't
I mean I'm not that old but I covered
both of Bill Clinton's campaigns and he
never won the popular vote became
president thanks to you lick total
college well I guess you could sort of
blame maybe Ross Perot for that if you
were for sure no because that's exactly
that no but that's true of that's
absolutely what happened of course Ross
Perot third party candidate but still
you had a guy who didn't win the
majority of popular vote who was
considered by most people certainly me
as a legitimate president why did that
change well I think what you're seeing
is that President Trump won the
electoral college he did not win the
popular vote Hillary Clinton repeats
over and over again but she won the
popular vote but right that's not the
contest that's actually not the game we
have to win the electoral college and
President Trump went to states like
Wisconsin Michigan Wisconsin being the
biggest one had Hillary Clinton played
the game a different way if she had
maybe tried for to win the electoral
college than the popular vote see the
thing is the founders really wanted our
country to be a federalist system they
wanted the states to be diverse they
wanted to basically you they did give
slightly more power to the smaller
states but they generally favored the
the more popular states but Democrats
see going forward California New York
Florida all of these big states making
decisions that they want like for
example Medicare for all but when some
states like Wyoming North Dakota South
Dakota Montana Kansas stamp their feet
and say no then the Democrats think that
that's unfair so they just want to
change the rules of the game the idea
that it's
racist is preposterous you bring up the
great point about Abraham Lincoln I also
just feel that it's Democrats squawking
because they're struggling to find a
message they're struggling to find unity
they just want to blame the system and
they give the appearance of one not
understanding our history number one
that's problem but number two not
appreciating our country and how our
founders set it up that's right they
could just run out of middle-class
economics that always works well that
was a big waste of time as well in our
lifetime and the electoral college is
not going to change in your
grandchildren's lifetime they might take
another run at it yeah yeah I pray for
that Dana thank you great to see you
tonight I mean